all right let's jump to the story we got
this from timcast.com Chinese
surveillance balloon may have contained
explosives designed to self-destruct
anytime you down something like this we
have to make assumptions such as that's
uh such as that said Air Force General
Glenn D Vanner I wonder if that's the
real reason they did not want to shoot
it down because the debris is one thing
but if it had some something in it
really bad I guess the concern is what
if it had a bomb would have had some
kind of device and shooting it down
would
yeah you know poison or a biological
weapon you said it before the show I
think John the EMP the best way to
deliver it would be or one of the best
ways would be via balloon because it's
so high up and then it's got just a wide
berth of explosives it goes higher than
an airplane can go to shoot it down like
if it's at 150 000 feet you know you
can't get a plane up that high really
there there was a a whole listen you
guys can go look it up but there's a
operation called operation hard tack in
the 50s and it was nuclear test and it
was also EMP tests and the EMP test they
were running they were detonating the
emps from balloons at about 150 000 feet
up
and the reason because that is the most
that's that's the most effective range
for an EMP to really do its damage down
on the ground and you can go read the
report it's a few pages long but it's
very interesting so when I saw that that
balloon floating across I thought
is there I wonder if there's an EMP in
that thing how many more balloons out
there floating around you know we've
always talked about what if the grid
went down you know we all know you guys
talk about that a lot but you know if if
you had no electricity in America for a
year you'd have 10 of the people left
that that's not me saying it that's all
the military strategists that have ever
looked at it you'd have about one out of
10 Americans would survive something
like that for a year it's almost
unsurvivable so an EMP uh an EMP also
this is an interesting thing that uh in
Iran and their in their War Manifesto
like how they would carry out a war they
find an EMP to be Sharia compliant
because the EMP itself does not mass
kill anybody it's what DMP causes that
mass kills everybody but the MP itself
does not cause a mass death matter of
fact it causes no death because it's way
up there it's Sharia compliance so
people don't realize that emps
are the go-to they're the go-to first
track weapon put everybody in the dark
so when I saw that that balloon I went I
wonder if there's an EMP in that thing
and maybe that's why they didn't shoot
it down I don't know they knew it was
coming for I think a week but that's
legit it sounds dumb to people oh that's
so stupid they're gonna send a balloon
up well that's you were saying it's
because they don't have heat signatures
or they have very low heat yeah they're
analog basically I mean you know there's
not a lot to them and they move so slow
and so high you know they're in between
the satellites and airspace and where
the airplanes fly so they're they're
kind of in this Zone where they're hard
to get to them and you know if you send
a missile in with an EMP you can see
that coming
you would see it take off and you go oh
there's a missile try to knock it down
this balloon just kind of floats in and
here's a balloon floating from Alaska to
South Carolina and
uh well did it actually have
self-destruct instructions aboard like
it was supposed to destroy itself
afterwards no idea I don't think anybody
knows anything about
any of it my first guess is that it was
like a good their version of like Google
Maps they were tracking they're trying
to like map the North America but they
just they're so poor communication with
the United States no one knew ahead of
time but then they blew it up so either
they're mapping like Google Maps and
they didn't want to tell anyone because
they're so secretive or they were
actually like tracking and mapping all
of our sensitive data on in purpose and
they came down on purpose they said it
was blown off course
um I thought it was blown up of course
that's the first thing I thought
wouldn't they have notified someone if
it got blown off course I mean Lincoln
was supposed to go meet with the Chinese
government and now he's not going to
because oh he's not yeah because they
couldn't like the balloon being blown
off course especially if they're like oh
it's just studying the weather like why
didn't you just say hey we lost our
large analog balloon could you please
let us know if you see it but it wasn't
blown off course because it was stopping
and hovering over nuclear Silo
installations and would sit there and
then it would start moving again and it
was sending data let's be realistic in
real time I yeah without a doubt I'd be
shocked if it was not just transmitting
data and the whole time they let it fly
slowly across the United States and
track that what if there was a
biological weapon placed in the balloon
so we want the balloon shot down
immediately why was it allowed blah blah
blah if they were I think I think
Montana would have been a great place to
shoot it down no offense to Montana but
a lot of big open space and so they
could quickly come in quarantine and
isolate maybe their concern was then
you're going to get into the Press is
going to be there you shoot it down are
you going to be able to contain the area
in time when the debris comes down
they're already searching for explosives
and they waited until it was over water
to take it out maybe that's what was
their concern they didn't know what it
happened it was over water in Alaska
well right it was over water in Alaska
there's nobody else it went over all of
Alaska and they said nothing it wasn't
until someone saw it right if you were
if you were worried there was a bio a
biological weapon on it I mean the least
populated areas over the water outside
of Alaska and then through Canada came
down and it came down through British
Columbia well
Alberta if it did have something on it
that was extremely dangerous and would
you know sure taking it out in Canada
would be the best option because I know
Americans I'm kidding I'm kidding
that's the real question Tom McDonald
would not appreciate that Canada doesn't
have the capabilities
[Laughter]
I love Canada man it's so sad to see
them getting railroaded by the
government with like the trucker convos
and stuff because they're the most cool
people they're like the most like oh
yeah I'll help you then yeah you're like
anything like my hair is on fire oh get
in the back of the car but man I'll take
you for a ride then I've played every
hockey rink in the whole nation of
Canada I've toured that country I bet
I've played 200 300 shows in Canada and
you're right the people you go to little
bitty towns like Lethbridge Alberta and
little you know Kamloops and those kind
of places yeah they're some of the
greatest people in the world in America
we talk about how these big cities are
very different from flyover states and
everything like that like it's even more
so in Canada because the population is
even smaller I mean my experience
because my family's Canadian has always
been you know going there to spend time
with them and they just make fun of
America everyone makes fun of Americans
but you want to be like you guys are not
unified at all so somebody's mentioning
that uh Alex Jones pointed out or Alex
Jones is saying it's a test balloon and
the next one 11 A.M that's what I'm
thinking or the next 60 what will happen
next time is you'll see 60 coming from
different direction well this is the
worst case scenario you see them all
coming at once it's like you ever see
that Fire in the Sky movie where they
sent one the alien sent like one thing
and that it was all this oh no what are
we gonna do what are we gonna do they
spent the whole movie trying to figure
out how to stop it they finally figured
I think it's called Fire in the Sky they
finally get rid of it and then like the
next day you just see thousands of them
coming and it's like oh oh dude we
couldn't even handle one freaking
balloon one what do you think Douglas
MacArthur or General Patton would have
done uh if a if an Italian or Nazi or
Japanese balloon had a floated across
Mainland us you blow it up you
immediately get that guy on the phone
the head and then you harangue them
publicly bad things would happen yeah
dude what if I was thinking last night
or this morning what if the government
was taken over by a foreign entity all
of a sudden the airwaves come up and
it's like we are in control everything's
okay it's the Chinese government's in
control who would even do anything about
it now like it's so we're so I feel so
fractured Society is so fractured wait
if there was a government if the
American government was taken over by a
foreign government yeah people would
just sitting there yeah all of a sudden
Joe Biden's not the president it's Xi
Jinping and he's like we've got it under
control wow yeah what if that happened
I've Got a Feeling there
it's the craziest thing I've ever heard
I have faith I hope certainly that will
never happen it's impossible this
Hunter Biden flew on Air Force to to
China not to negotiate any kind of
subservience but to tell them off and
say no and that five million dollar loan
loan forgivable loan was was them saying
please please take this money and leave
yeah forgive us it freaks me out that
Alex said that's a test balloon because
I am not that's what isn't that what
Jack said that's literally what I said
yeah that's what you guys all said I
said it's a literal trial balloon
they're they're sending it through to
see our response and our response was an
inability to handle it we were I think I
think the real fear was if it had
explosives on it or something and they
shot out of the sky there could what if
there was a gravity bomb on it like like
a one Megaton bomb and the trick was if
we shut it down we nuke ourselves so
we're everyone's sitting here being like
I should have shut it down well there's
probably some things he could have done
for sure instead of just like being like
we're gonna let it fly over the whole
country because assuming he had a bomb
it could have been waiting till it's it
over its Target you know what I mean so
if you think there's a problem your best
bet Montana sorry Montana I'm not trying
to be a dick I think you're an awesome
State
yeah off the Aleutian Islands I mean did
they know the freezing water did they
detect it when it was in Alaska yeah oh
yeah they saw it when it they saw it
they've now confirmed they saw it coming
across the Pacific they just didn't say
anything just didn't say anything yeah
so so what if
they were letting stuff like this happen
you know what what if Joe Biden was
working at the behest of the Chinese
Communist party or what if huh no one
even said anything about it till
civilians caught it that's right and
then they had to admit that yeah it is
and then they did nothing yeah nothing
maybe they were on standby and they're
like if it veers off course towards a
major city we'll take it out
maybe they've waited till they knew the
whole world was looking like this all
day long just like that to start sending
in the balloons because we never look up
we're always looking down dude and now
they know that if they do sense
something the Americans are afraid of it
they got that in the bag this is all Art
of War stuff like they're just gauging
what we did and now next time we'll have
to be a little harder if we see another
balloon they know that ahead of time
they're gonna I think you're right we're
gonna see multiple balloons if they see
another balloon dude that's an act of
war in my opinion I agree that's not an
accident I agree I think this wasn't an
accident and there were two one went
over Latin America but I think right
before they go for Taiwan that's why
they did this how will we respond and so
this is this is the analogy I said last
week
guy who's planning on robbing a liquor
store knows having the gun in New York
is illegal but he doesn't care because
he's already intending to do something
substantially worse which is use a gun
to Rob someone China when they're about
to invade Taiwan they know our reaction
is going to be some kind of War response
so they don't care if if we're mad about
a balloon like the balloon is
inconsequential compared to how pissed
off we're going to be when they move on
Taiwan they know so I'm willing to bet
we will see some kind of sign like this
right before Taiwan gets hit and and
China's already been mobilizing uh
warships and Fighters and Taiwan is on a
high alert mobilizing their their Navy
their Air Force their their Fighters
whatever they have and then this happens
I'm like oh boy
it's common well I think they sorry I'm
just gonna say I think China also wins
by showing the American people uh that
we don't it confirms for a lot of people
why you shouldn't have confidence in the
government right if you're someone who's
already skeptical of the Biden
Administration or our military strength
and we just let a balloon float across
the country for days China wins because
it now knows the American people are at
war with its own government thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time